[Musique]
bonjour je me présente je suis Jérémy en
bielle chef du restaurant de l'arche
aujourd'hui je vous propose de cuisiner
la poule au pot avec la poule de Houdan
et pour ça je vous propose de
m'accompagner et de voir tous les locaux
avec qui je travaille au quotidien
[Musique]
donc la première étape c'est d'aller à
la boucherie des arts sur sur oudans
pour récupérer de quoi faire la farce
pour la poule au pot et aussi la pièce
du boucher pour le restaurant pour le
service du jour
[Musique]
je vais dans le secteur de la
restauration depuis à peu près une
quinzaine d'années on a quand même un
beau domaine on a un beau site on a un
bon restaurant et il y a énormément de
choses à faire dessus donc voilà après
une identité sur le restaurant
je pense pas qu'il y en ait vraiment une
l'idée c'est de faire
du familial du voilà de la cuisine de
terroir la cuisine de grand-mère en fait
de faire simple c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on travaille avec les
locaux qui choisissent les produits pour
nous et voilà je leur fais totalement
confiance aujourd'hui sur le choix des
produits je connais pas toutes les
saisons de tout donc moi je vais voir
mon maraîcher je dis bah alors
qu'est-ce qui va quelle est la fin de la
saison pour tel produit qu'est ce qui va
commencer demain la poissonnière c'est
pareil voilà Nathalie elle me dit bah
tiens là en ce moment c'est la
Saint-Jacques faut y aller et ben on met
la Saint-Jacques à la carte quand même
dire écoute la Saint-Jacques c'est fini
hop on arrête et à chaque fois en fait
on est dans la communication à ce
niveau-là c'est eux qui me disent
respectent tel produit pour que tu
respectes la sérénité des produits
on va commencer par la boucherie des
arts à Houdan qui me fournit toute la
toute la viande donc là on va faire une
farce à base de veau après on va aller
chez befruit qui est le maraîcher on va
chercher tout ce qui est échalotes les
oignons les poireaux les carottes le
persil les champignons après on va aller
chez Julien Lecoq donc chez la ferme le
coq à Lognes
où on va récupérer la poule de Houdan
salut
[Musique]